PETE FRISELLA: Hi, everybody.
Welcome.
My name is Pete Frisella.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Analytics team.
Today, I just wanted to
give you a quick update.
There's quite a few things that
happened the last month or so,
and I thought it would be
good to share the highlights
with you and give you
an overview of all
the great new
things that we have
available for you
in Google Analytics.
Well, the first thing
I wanted to start with
was the Dimensions
and Metrics Explorer.
We just released a new version
of this tool just a few days
ago, actually, and it adds a
whole bunch of new features.
So let's just go
right to the tool,
and we'll take a look at what
some of these great features
are.
So this is actually coming live
from the internet right now,
and this is what's deployed
and currently available for you
to take a look at.
So there's a few new things
that we added to this tool.
So one, what this tool
does is it gives you
an overview of all the
dimensions and metrics that
are available in the
Core Reporting API.
It helps you understand what
the valid combinations are,
the descriptions of these
different dimensions metrics.
It provides a whole
bunch of information
to help you navigate all
these different data points.
So one of the first new
things that we added
was an ability to switch modes.
So prior to this update,
there was only really one way
to look at this data,
which was the API names.
And now we have two additional
modes that are web and app.
So if I go here and
expand all of these,
you'll see this is a list
of all the dimensions
and metrics that we have.
And now when we
switch to web mode,
we'll now get a full list of
all the different dimensions
and metrics, but also
include web names.
So this is brand new, and we
also have apps, of course.
So you can come here and try
this out and give it a whirl
yourself.
There's also a new feature here
called Only Allow In Segments.
So this will only show
you dimensions and metrics
that are allowed in segments.
So if you click
the check box, it
will eliminate any
dimensions and metrics
that can't be used in segments.
And of course, you can
do search capability.
So if you're only looking for
specific dimensions or metrics,
you can definitely
search for those,
and it automatically
adjusts the search results
based on your query.
Secondly, there's
another big feature
around the detailed view.
So if you click into
any dimension or metric,
you'll see a very detailed view
of that particular dimension
or metric.
So for example, we now include
the web name, the app name,
and we also have these
additional attributes like data
type and whether it's
allowed in segments.
And if you go to
the top, we can see
how this might look for
something that's very detailed.
So for example, the custom
variables or columns,
for example, has quite a
few different attributes,
things like index range and
the premium index range.
So all this information is now
available through this tool.
And it's a lot faster
since once it loads,
you don't have page
reloads anymore.
It just automatically will load
different views very quick.
You can see how
quick it is to switch
between these different views.
And then finally,
this has all been
updated to use the Metadata API.
So we recently relaunched
this Metadata API
back in early October.
And this gives
programmatic access
to dimensions and metrics.
And this tool was actually
built using this API,
so it automatically
will update itself
when we release new data.
So that was the first update
I wanted to share with you.
The next one is
the Query Explorer.
So a lot of you are probably
familiar with this tool.
It's a great way to explore your
reporting data from the Core
Reporting API.
And it gives you access to
all the dimensions and metrics
and you can query up to seven
dimensions and 10 metrics
in a query.
So it gives you a lot of
data that you can pull out
of the Core Reporting API.
So this is what it looks like.
I think probably a lot of
you are familiar with it.
So let's just take a
look at the tool itself.
This is another,
again, a live view.
So I think this is
something that you probably
wouldn't notice that we've
updated this, but some of you
may have caught it.
But we've actually updated this
tool to use the Metadata API.
So again, this was a new
API that we released,
and it allows
programmatic access
to dimensions and metrics.
Prior to this,
the Query Explorer
was using kind of a static
weight to bring in this data,
and now it's actually all
being dynamically loaded
into the Query Explorer.
So what you're going
to notice, and it's
a little bit different
for you guys,
is that you get a
little bit more data
for each particular
dimension or metric.
You'll see on the right
hand side, in this view,
you'll see how it's
changing as we scroll
over different
dimensions and metrics.
This is all actually being
generated dynamically
and coming from
the Metadata API.
So the good thing
for you guys is
that it's giving you a little
bit more data, such as the data
type and whether it's
allowed in segments.
So this information's now
available through the Query
Explorer.
And this is
something that's new.
It wasn't really publicly
announced or anything,
but this is a great,
great little update
that gives you a little
bit more information.
And it's a good
way to showcase how
you can use the Metadata API.
If you're interested in
this kind of information
such as dimensions or metrics,
both of these tools really
highlight how you can build
these applications using
the Metadata API.
So if you're
interested in that, you
can definitely visit
our developer site
and learn a little bit
more about that API
and how it works.
Great.
So those are two
quick ones, but pretty
big changes for some
of you, I think,
in terms of getting access to
all the core reporting data.
So let's go back into
the presentation.
A new parameter that we
introduced into the Core
Reporting API this past month,
it's called the Sampling Level.
And this is kind of an effort
to bring the Core Reporting
API to be a little bit more
consistent with the experience
that you have in the web
interface, for example.
And this is kind of important.
So, some of you, you've probably
been in the web interface.
You've done a report,
maybe a custom report,
or seen some query,
and you'll notice
that it says that it's
actually sampled, but based
on a certain number
of visits, right?
And if you click
this little icon
on the top right-hand corner,
you get this drop-down,
and you're actually able to
slide this little control back
and forth to either go for
faster processing or higher
precision.
So this actually controls
the sampling rate
for your particular query.
This was not available
in the Core Reporting
API prior this
update, and now we've
added a new
parameter that brings
this consistency across the two.
So what does this actually mean?
So from your perspective, if
you're querying using the Core
Reporting API, there's now
this new parameter called
&samplingLevel=, which you
are able to set when you make
a request to the
Core Reporting API.
And this is again very
consistent with what
you see in the web interface.
So you can set it at
three different levels.
One is faster, or you
can use a default value,
or you can use higher precision.
So default is, if you don't
provide this query parameter,
it will just use a
default value, which
is what would be
the same as what
you'd see in the web interface.
And then you can also set it
to faster or higher precision.
This is also important.
We get a lot of requests
from people or questions
from people around their
queries not matching the result
that they see in
the web interface.
And there's usually two main
reasons why this happens,
why these requests
are not the same.
One is that either the actually
query's a little bit different.
So there's some queries in the
UI that cannot be reproduced
through the API, and that would
result in a different result,
a different response from
the Core Reporting API,
so you might have different
numbers for certain queries.
The other reason why you
might get different responses
from the Core Reporting API is
because of the sampling level.
And prior to this query
parameter being available,
there was really no way
for you to set the sampling
level in the Core Reporting API.
So it was harder
to match what you
would see in the web interface.
So this brings it
back in parity now,
and definitely if you
use this query parameter,
you'll see the response
that you get back
from the Core Reporting API
is just a little bit different
and includes a couple
new parameters for you.
So what will happen is,
you make the request,
you set the sampling level,
and in your response,
you'll see these
different fields,
these different properties
that are now available.
One is the containsSampledData,
and this just lets you know,
and this isn't
new, but this lets
you know whether the
response that you got
contained data that
was sampled or not.
So this has always been
there, it's nothing new,
but what is new is we've added
two different properties here
to give you additional
information about the sampling
that took place.
The first one is
the sample size.
The sampleSize just indicates
how many visits were actually
used to calculate this
particular data that you're
seeing that's been returned back
from the Core Reporting API.
And the sampleSpace
lets you know
what was the total number of
samples that were actually
available to make this query.
So for example, there might
have been 21 million sessions
or samples available.
We only use, in this example,
385,000 of those to get you
data you need and
respond that back to you.
So the reason we do this is
it's a lot quicker to bring back
data, and statistically,
it actually
is very close to the
correct responses
that you would get for
the larger sample size.
But it just makes
it a lot quicker
and gives you
reports very quick.
So these two numbers are
new, and a lot of you
have asked for this data
because it helps you, again,
bring consistency between the
web interface and the Core
Reporting API.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, if you use
the web interface,
you would see this
kind of result.
You would have this little
tooltip or notification when
you have a sample report,
and it would show you
this report is based
on this number visits,
and it would give
you a percentage.
And this just lets you know
that the report was sampled,
and this is kind of what we're
using to calculate this data.
So let's see how this would
apply to these new fields
that we have through
the Core Reporting API.
So one, the
containsSampledData is kind of
equivalent to seeing this
little notification bar.
So this gives you
the same indication
that the data that you're
looking at right now
is sampled.
The other one's pretty easy.
We have the sampleSize.
And this corresponds to
that particular number
you would see in the
web interface, which
is the number of visits
that the report is based on.
So these are very consistent
now between the two.
And finally is that
you may want to be
able to calculate
this 1.77%, so you
want to calculate this kind
of coverage or percentage
of visits that are used.
And we can use a sampleSpace
to figure out this calculation.
And it's quite straightforward.
We know the sampleSize and
we know the sampleSpace,
so it's just a
matter of dividing
these two to get your percentage
of visits that are used.
So with this new parameter
and these new properties
that we have available
in the response,
you can be consistent with.
If you're building
an application
and you want to be able
to expose this information
to your users, these
properties allow to do that.
Another thing that we
released this past month
was relative dates in
the Core Reporting API.
So again, this was
another feature
that was requested
by some users,
and it actually is
pretty powerful,
and it helps if you're
trying to build reports that
are kind of ongoing,
and you want
them to be relative to a
specific date, for example.
So how this works is, whenever
you make a request to the Core
Reporting API, there's
always two parameters
that you-- so there's a couple
parameters you need to provide,
and two of them
are the start-date
and the end-date So
what period of time
would you like this data for?
So the acceptable
values have always been,
of course, the year,
month, day, which
is what everybody's been using
since the inception of the Core
Reporting API.
And we've added three
new different values
that you can provide in place of
the standard year, month, day.
They are today,
yesterday, and NdaysAgo.
So with these three
values, you can basically
create any query you'd
like with relative dates
for any period of time.
It gives you that kind of
flexibility to do that.
And I'll show you what that
means in a second here.
So for example, just
say you have a report,
and you don't want
it to be a set date.
You just want it to
be every seven days.
So anytime you
query for this data,
you just want the last
seven days worth of data.
So with these new
parameters, you
could set the start-date to,
for example, seven days ago,
and the end-date to yesterday.
And this would give
you the last seven
days starting from yesterday.
And it would always give
you that last seven days
no matter when you query
it because now we're
using relative dates.
Again, last 10 days
would be very similar.
The end-date would be
today, for example,
and the start-date
would be nine days ago.
So you've got to
be careful here,
and something you'll
want to make note of
is that when you're looking for
something like the last 10 days
and you're including
today, intuitively, you
might think that
it's 10 days ago,
but it's actually nine days
ago, to actually include
that full 10 days.
So just something
to keep in mind,
when you're making these
queries and setting them up,
make sure you're actually
getting the correct number
of days that you
think you're getting
based on the NdaysAgo parameter.
And then finally, just a
simple example, but if you're
going to do today now,
you can do something like,
you always want today's data.
Then you would just
set the start-date
to today and the
end-date to today,
and you would get the
data always from today.
Another important
thing to note is
that this is based on
the time zone that's
set in your particular
profile, so if you
are set for Pacific
time in your profile,
these relative dates will
be resolved to real dates
based on that time zones.
So just something to
keep in mind again,
that's how it works.
Pretty straightforward,
simple feature, but definitely
something that gives
you more flexibility
in terms of how you want
to set up your reports.
And then recently, we
released some new data
in a Core Reporting API.
Another, again,
feature or data points
that people were asking
for for quite some time,
it was one of our top feature
requests on our issue tracker,
was AdSense data.
So we've added a whole bunch
of new AdSense metrics.
You can visit the Dimensions
and Metrics Explorer
to look at those metrics and
see what they are and learn more
about them.
We also added a few more
time dimensions, ga:isoYear,
and isoYearIsoWeek.
And again, these work with
the isoWeek dimensions,
and they should be used
together and not used
with the Gregorian
calendar entries.
Like gaWeek should not
be used with these ones.
But again, these were
features that people
have been asking
for for a long time,
so if you didn't know
we released those,
you can definitely take
a look at those now.
And then finally, we
added a new AdWords,
the adKeywordMatchType,
which basically shows you
which keyword
types were applied,
or which match types were
applied to a specific keyword.
Again, these are all available
through the Dimensions
and Metrics Explorer.
You can check them out.
And they're available, of
course, in the Query Explorer,
so you can go in
there and try the data
and see what it looks like.
All right, so this
is kind of a wrap-up.
Those are the big features
we released this past month.
There was a lot of
data that we released.
There was a new Dimensions and
Metrics Explorer and the Query
Explorer and, of course, a
new sampling level parameter.
You can learn more about this
from the Core Reporting API
reference.
And of course, you can
visit the tools themselves
at the resources that
we've provided here.
And then also going forward,
how do you stay up to date?
So we release a lot of things
in the API developer relations.
We do our best to make
sure you guys understand
what's coming out
and what features
might be relevant to you.
But you can always visit our
blog at analytics.blogspot.com
and get updates there.
We have our Google
Analytics G+ profile.
And of course, you
follow me @pfrisella,
and I usually will
post things that we've
released so everybody
can learn about them.
And then of course,
I really recommend
you subscribe to our changelogs.
We have a great
set of changelogs,
especially if you're using
the Core Reporting API,
the management API.
We have some detailed
changelogs for you,
and you can subscribe to
them through RSS feeds,
or you can just visit the
page itself and take a look.
Great.
With that, I'd like to thank
you for joining me today.
It was quick, but the
update has been completed,
so thank you very much and
I'll see you next time.